[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight update video I still have two
seasons left of the Game of Thrones
series that I am givin away and I will
announce both winners in my next video
if you want a chance to win one of them
just make sure you use the link that's
down in the description and good luck to
everyone who is participating I actually
have several new updates today that I
want to talk about so let's just get
right into it I found this first report
to be very interesting because it can be
a big clue as to what we can expect to
see at some point next season the main
headquarters for Game of Thrones filming
is at Titanic studios in Belfast
Northern Ireland and now that filming
has begun the activity around the city
has really started to increase and
recently a fan was near Titanic studios
and they took some photos of a new set
being built on the studio lot now I
cannot confirm what this building will
be used for but by the looks of the
color of this building it appears to be
something we would tend to see in the
King's Landing area or possibly even
further south than that as far as I know
I don't remember ever seeing a building
or castle of this color in the north but
it does have a very similar color to the
rooftops that we have all seen in King's
Landing it looks like this is going to
be a pretty big structure and if you
look closely you can see a staircase on
the side of this building as well but a
report came out that made this new set
even more interesting apparently this
structure has underwent a controlled
fire test and this might be why they
actually build it outside because they
plan on torching this building just like
they did when they built the hut in
season 6 when Daenerys burnt all of the
calls alive I think this is a very
exciting development because this could
be a clue that we will see some dragon
fire in the king's landing area which
does make sense because Daenerys and
John are gonna have to take care of
Cersei at some point and if they can't
draw Cersei out of the city then
Daenerys and her dragons will most
likely burn a place to the ground I know
we all remember the vision Daenerys had
at the house of the undying when she was
walking through the Great Hall where the
Iron Throne is kept the building
appeared to have some significant fire
damage to its roof which most likely
means dragons were raining down fire
upon them the color of this new building
definitely was
something from King's Landing and if
they're doing controlled fire tests on
it then that can only mean one thing to
me this building will burn to the ground
but before I start speculating too much
I'm just gonna wait and see what other
information comes out as filming
continues if this building burns outside
I'm sure we're gonna see some leaked
photos and if Daenerys is anywhere near
this set when this happens and I think
we can all guess what is gonna happen
next so just be patient and stay tuned
my friends because I will absolutely
keep us all up to date on any new
developments now let's move on to the
next photo that I have like I said
earlier in this video filming has just
begun and the actors have been spotted
all around Belfast this past week and
some of the photos are now starting to
circulate online I know some of you have
been asking me about Gendry and where he
might be and whether or not we're gonna
see him again well hopefully today I can
come close to answering that question
for you someone was able to snap a
picture of Gendry Gilly in grey worm all
together walking around Belfast
what I find interesting about this photo
is none of these actors have ever filmed
scenes together before so it seems kind
of odd that they would all be hanging
out together unless they all have scenes
together in the eighth and final season
and honestly it makes sense because all
three of these actors should be in
Winterfell together at some point next
season Sam and Gilly arrived in
Winterfell when the season 7 finale when
Sam and Brian had their little chat
together and brain had the flashback or
Rhaegar and Lyanna sweating so Gilly is
already there in Winterfell and grey
worm is heading that way now Daenerys
and her entire army are heading to
Winterfell with John and this is where
they will most likely set up camp and
strategize how they will try and defeat
the night King so we should see John
Daenerys grey worm and everyone else in
their camp and Winterfell very early on
during season eight and we should see
Gendry there soon - personally I figured
Gendry may have left the wall when John
and everyone else went to the dragon pit
parlay with Cersei the last time we all
saw a jury was when he alerted everyone
at the wall that John and company were
in trouble and before Gendry actually
volunteered to go on this mission beyond
the wall he was actually supposed to go
to Winterfell instead to forge new
weapons when Davos found ginjury in
King's Landing he actually has
Gendry to join their team and right
before ginjury met john in the cave on
Dragonstone davos told ginjury he was
going to be going to Winterfell to forge
new weapons but instead Gentry ran into
the cave and he told John exactly who he
was in the rest is history so as of
right now I'm not exactly sure where
Gendry is that at this moment because we
didn't see him at the wall when torment
and barrack had to run for their lives
and we didn't see ginjury in Winterfell
either when arya killed Littlefinger or
when Sam and Gilly arrived but by the
looks of this photo Genji is hanging out
with the cast and Belfast so I would
expect to see him in the north during
season 8 considering he is hanging out
what Gilly I can only assume they're
gonna have a scene together or at least
be seen in the same room together
personally I expect to see nearly every
single character at Winterfell
except for everyone still on Cersei side
of course but filming has just begun and
more photos will come out so I'm gonna
hold off on speculating too much right
now
sir Davos was also spotted in Belfast as
well and I really don't have much to say
about this other than I love sir Davos
his character so shout out to the onion
night I'm really looking forward to
seeing him again in the final season I
really hope he can survive all of the
bloodshed we are about to witness
another thing I wanted to mention was
that any of you happened to hear what
kid Harrington said after he read the
script for the final season apparently
after KITT finished reading the script
for the last six episodes he broke down
into tears and started crying he
actually admitted that he cried when he
read it but he didn't necessarily
specify what made him cry it may have
been because of what happens to everyone
at the end or it could have just been
because he knows it's almost over either
way it kind of bummed me out because it
is almost over and if any of my
favourite characters die during this
season then there is really no chance of
them coming back to life in the show
because it's gonna be over for good I
have really enjoyed the whole game of
thorns experience and it is gonna really
suck when it comes to an end and I can
only hope they make a great successor
show as soon as possible so we can keep
this whole universe alive on television
but anyway I have one more thing I want
to show you then I will let you get out
of here so you can go along with your
day I have a new update about the
Riverrun location and don't worry I
won't be talking about Edna
Holle this time I know some of you hate
when I even mentioned that character's
name but hey I can only talk about what
new information is out there and
sometimes there isn't much to go on but
there is a new development about this
location I have to thank my friend zip
who lives near the set once again
because he went out of his way to take
these photos and send them to me if you
remember the last time I talked about
this location and appeared to be
abandoned at the moment those security
guards were no longer there watching the
property and it looked like they had
removed more of the castle front that
was used for the Tully's castle but zip
had stopped by this location again and
all of a sudden a giant green screen was
put up and they had some of the road
closed off as well so it appears this
set will be active once again but it
might actually have nothing to do with
the Riverrun castle itself this new
green screen is actually about a few
hundred feet away from the castle when
it's facing the opposite direction so I
can't confirm what they're gonna
actually use this for but it's very
interesting this green screen was just
recently put up and now they have some
cones in the road with some signs there
too so I think something is definitely
about to be filmed in this area and it
could have something to do with Casterly
Rock
they use this location for several
different parts of Westeros actually but
they have also used this land to film
scenes for Casterly Rock also which is
interesting because there is some
potential we could see the Lannisters
homeland once again after all the wars
are over who's to say Terry and or Jamie
doesn't decide to go and retire and
Casterly Rock and live out the rest of
their life there or if by some miracle
Cersei happens to live maybe she goes to
Casterly Rock
who really knows but now that this green
scream was just recently put here I
won't rule anything out and according to
zip which is the person who lives near
this set and sent me these photos he
said this location was also used to film
the battle on the sea with your own
Greyjoy there is a small studio here too
and there is a carpark here also and
that's where they filmed the battle on
the sea with Joran Yara and Theon zip
actually sent me a photo from Google
Maps and it gives a really good look at
the entire area so you can get a good
feel for this location you can see how
close the castle at Riverrun is to the
actual new green screen and you can see
where the Lannisters had set up their
camp before
when Jaime and Bronn were here to meet
with the Freys and the blackfish but
just like everything else I reported on
today I don't want to speculate too much
because there just isn't enough evidence
yet to say what they're gonna be filming
here but I can confirm this area was
used for Riverrun Casterly Rock Inn they
filmed the sea battle here on the lot so
if you want to take a guess at what
they're gonna be doing here that's a
good place to start as soon as I find
out any more information I will let you
all know right away so let me know what
you think about everything down below if
you have any interesting theories on the
photos I've shown throughout this video
please leave it in the comments because
I'd love to hear it I want to thank Zipp
once again for sending me those photos
and I want to thank all of you for
stopping by and checking out the video I
really appreciate your support during
this long night into the off season I
also want to thank everyone who supports
this channel on patreon because without
your help this wouldn't be possible so
thank you all very much I hope you all
have a great day I'll see you in the
next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
you